[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi, I'm Xeres, a developer
advocate here at Google,
back again in our
AdWords API series.
In the first video, we looked
at what the AdWords API is
and what it can be used for.
In this video, I want to get
you to your first API call.
This is a complex process,
so I wanted to break it down
for you, step by step.
You may want to pause the
video from time to time
so that you can follow along.
This will open the door for
you to take full advantage
of the AdWords API.
We're going to use
Java and Eclipse.
If you don't use Java,
you can accomplish
all of this with
the client libraries
in these other languages.
The concepts are all the same.
Here are the six steps you
need to follow-- request
a developer token,
create a test AdWords MCC
or My Client Centered Account
and a test AdWords client
account, set up your
development environment,
set up OAuth2 access, configure
your client application,
and, finally, make
your first API call.
So let's start.
To be able to use
the AdWords API,
you need to have an
AdWords MCC account.
If you don't have one,
you can request one here.
Next, request a developer token.
This is what allows
your application
to connect to the API.
Log into your
AdWords MCC account.
In the gear menu,
choose Account Settings.
Then, in the menu on the
left, click AdWords API Center
and fill out the form to
apply for a developer token.
Check your mail for
another application form
and complete it.
You should receive it
within two business days.
You can also find
that form here.
While your developer
token is pending approval,
you can start using it to
develop your code with a test
MCC account.
API calls you make to the
test MCC account will not
serve any ads.
Use this link to create
your test MCC account.
After you create it, use
the AdWords web interface
to create a test client account,
under that test MCC account.
And in that test client account,
create a few test campaigns
and save the client account
customer ID for later.
Now, let's turn our attention
to your development environment.
If you're an experienced
Java developer,
you probably already have
your environment just the way
you want it.
If not, we will walk
through the recommended set
up for the Java
client libraries now.
First, install
Eclipse from here.
Eclipse for Java
EE is recommended,
because it includes Maven.
Then, download the Maven
AdWords client library for Java
from here.
The client library handles all
the back end API calls for you
and exposes friendly
objects to work with.
This particular archive
also includes code samples
which are very helpful.
Extract the files and open them
in Eclipse by choosing Import,
Existing Maven Project.
If you get Maven
compilation errors,
you may have to install
additional M2E connectors
for Eclipse.
If you still have some
errors in the palm.XML,
you can ignore them.
The code samples should
still run properly.
Now, let's move on
to setting up OAuth2.
The average API using OAuth2
to allow your application
to operate on behalf of
your AdWords account.
To get set up,
follow these steps.
Go to the Google
Developer Console
and login with your
MCC credentials.
Create a new project, go to
APIs & Auth in the left menu
and select Credentials.
Follow the workflow to
create a new client ID
and, when prompted, choose
Installed Application
as the application
type and Other
as the installed
application type.
It will then display your
newly created client ID, client
secret, and redirect URIs.
Save these for later as well.
Just a quick note
that client here
means your application, not the
AdWords MCC or client account.
Now, let's go back to Eclipse.
In the client library
and samples project,
open the Ads.Properties
file here.
Now you'll need
all of these values
that we've been
saving for later.
First, enter your developer
token on this line.
It's OK if it's
not approved yet,
since we're using a test
account customer ID.
Then, enter your test client
customer ID on this line.
Enter your OAuth2 client ID and
client secret on these lines.
Then enter the name of your
application or organization
on this line.
You can leave any other
values at their defaults.
You'll notice that there is
a line for a refresh token.
This token is used
by the client library
to generate new OAuth
tokens, as needed.
The client library has a utility
to retrieve that refresh token,
which we can use now.
In Eclipse, find
GetRefreshToken.Java
and execute it.
The Eclipse console
will print a URL.
Open a browser and
log into AdWords
with your test MCC account.
Then, copy that URL
into the browser.
Click Accept and copy the code
back into the Eclipse console
where prompted.
The console will then
print a refresh token.
Copy that into the
Ads.Properties file.
I know.
It's a lot, right?
But this file should now contain
all the necessary information
to make API calls against your
test AdWords client account.
So, in Eclipse, open
up GetCampaigns.Java
and execute it.
The console should print a
listing of the test campaigns
in your test account.
Congratulations.
You just made an API call
with the client library.
It was a long journey,
but now, you're
ready to explore the
power of the AdWords API.
Thanks for watching and
this will all be worth it,
I promise.
[MUSIC PLAYING]